from 1993 to 2000 boy meets world was a
tgif
staple the show shared a friday prime
time block with kid-friendly sitcoms
family matters and step by step
when those two shows moved on boy meets
world endured sitting comfortably
alongside sabrina the teenage witch and
various other shows for the friday
primetime blog
on boy meets world writer strong played
corey's best friend sean hunter
in contrast to corey's idyllic life
shawn's storylines often had the
teenager grapple with some serious life
issues
he was abandoned by his stepmother
several times and he lost his father
soon after they reunited for starters
it was all the things that you taught me
that made me wonder if it was the right
place for me or not
but you didn't teach me enough after boy
meets world wrapped the world saw less
and less of strong
he disappeared from television sets for
years until he reprised the role of sean
all grown up for girl meets world years
later strong opened up about why his
presence became scarce
it turns out the same storylines that
made him memorable have something to do
with the reason why hollywood seemingly
won't cast him anymore
in an interview with vice the actor
admitted that his desire to be
considered a serious professional
clouded his judgment during his time on
boy meets world as an adult he now
recognizes his aloofness
i wanted to be a poet and academic
writer there was definitely a period
where i thought i was way cooler than
boy meets world
as a result the writers wrote more
dramatic storylines to keep the teenage
strong
interested in his role regardless of
their efforts he was still miserable
he didn't enjoy living up to the
expectations that came along with fame
he recalled one instance when he
participated in a sale with the stars
charity cruise that left him scarred
regarding the fans on the boat strong
told vice they want a certain version of
you
whether that's sean hunter or this
perfect teen idol boyfriend and suddenly
you have to be that person 24 hours a
day
strong nearly quit boy meets world soon
after but finished the show's run with
the support of his parents
after boy meets world ended strong
enrolled at columbia university per his
website
according to mental flaws his famous
classmates included anna paquin
julia stiles and joseph gordon-levitt
their feature film stardom meant he
received less attention from the media
while in school
which he preferred during his studies
strong stayed away from hollywood
only taking one semester off to film the
indie horror hit
cabin fever
he continued his education after
colombia and earned an mfa in fiction
and literature from bennington college
afterwards strong returned to work in
the entertainment industry
instead of television roles he took on
more horror films including 2017's
borderland pulse 3 and captain fever 2
spring fever finding that he preferred
to remain behind the camera
strong also began co-directing short
films with his brother in between
projects he also lends his voice to
narrate audiobooks
since his reprisal of sean hunter on
girl meets world strong has added voice
over work to his list of credits
including the disney animated shows
mighty magiswords and star vs the forces
of evil
the next gen spin-off girl meets world
saw the return of writer strong to
network television
although he was reluctant to return he
said he was able to find a compromise
with the show
i knew that playing sean again was going
to be the final nail in the coffin of
ever doing anything else as an actor so
i did a trade
strong originally asked for seven
episodes but ended up directing
18 of them for the show which ran for
three seasons
former co-stars ben savage also directed
a handful of girl meets world episodes
bringing the history of the show full
circle strong is now a husband and a
father he married actress alexandra
barreto in 2013
and they have one son check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite childhood stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one